- [Interviewer] All right Ray, Ray,
where are you from originally,
where'd you grow up?
- [Ray] Oakland.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family,
you grew up with both your parents?
- Yeah, for a little while.
Um, as a child,
they would um, they would get drunk.
It was my father and he had a little job,
but when he'd get drunk,
he would always beat
my mother up, you know,
argue with her and do
all kind of stuff to her,
and me and my brother,
we used to get upset and then
she would take it out on us,
trying to get back at him.
And,
it was terrible and then sometimes
my brother got molested one time
and then he end up
getting killed behind it.
'Cause my father and mother were fighting
and he ran out in the
street and got hit by a car.
- [Interviewer] Oh my God, what age?
- He was like three years old.
Yeah, so I end up
hurting this dude that ran
over my little brother.
Later on I end up shooting him.
Nobody really knows I did
it, but I got my revenge.
And it bothers me a lot of times
to think about it, that I did it.
I kind of regret it, but
he killed my brother,
he ran over him in the car.
- [Interviewer] I mean did--
- My little brother, yeah.
- [Interviewer] On purpose or?
Or it was just an accident?
- Accident probably, most likely.
But I just feel like I'm regretful
'cause I think it was an accident.
But I,
I still did it.
I feel guilty about it a lot of times.
You know, I hear, "You're going to Hell,
"you're going to Hell, it's murder."
Stuff like that, voices,
from time to time and it troubles me, so,
I will end up going to
the right hospital for it
just so they can give me medications.
I could never tell 'em what I did
and what was really bothering
me, the voices that I heard.
I found out later that my dad,
he was in a mental hospital too.
My mother, she was from Texas,
she was a good woman
'til he started, really
making her drink and he used
to make a mess of my mother
(muttering) and I used to hate him.
He put his car on the flat,
do stuff like that.
Well she used to take it out on us.
She just made me get in
the box when I was little,
mad at him, trying to take it out on him.
"You're just like him,"
make me get in the box.
I'd stay in there for hours.
I'd say, "Mama, please don't
make me get in the box,
"please don't put me in a box."
Make me stay in the box
when I was little.
It all because of him.
I never had a car in my life.
I had an under-the-table job before,
but because of my conditions,
it's hard for me to kinda
deal with people like that
'cause I end up getting upset and
I go back into my old way of thinking.
Murder,
I did it once and I'd do it again.
You know, I'll kill you.
But um, yeah.
So now I'm older now.
I'm still dealing with them, I'm homeless.
I stay away from all the
people that I used to know.
Most of those have fallen
off and died and shot,
whatever, sick, gone away, jail, prison.
I'm still here, but my life is empty
and I really don't have a whole
lotta good times in my life.
Lotta suffering.
Without, uneducated.
I wish I coulda been a
lawyer, doctor or a judge
or something like that.
I miss my mom.
(sighs)
(crying quietly)
So now I do stuff to
myself because it has,
mistreat myself.
Wanted to die.
(sighs)
I don't really have anything in my life.
I think that's the reason why, maybe,
my life has been like that.
(sighs)
There's a lot of stuff
that happened to my mom.
She died from,
from dealing with my father,
beating her and doing stuff to her.
(crying)
The way she used to treat me,
I don't think she loved
me at all. (crying)
A lot of pain.
A lot of pain, pain. (crying)
Oh. (crying)
I'm trying just to learn
how to deal with (sighs)
deal with it. (crying)
I hardly have no friends.
(sighs)
I can't have friends, I don't
know how to have friends.
We end up getting into fights.
I had a girlfriend, I had
a girlfriend before, but,
just
they say I'm too crazy.
Too strict, too jealous, whatever.
(sniffs)
- [Interviewer] Do you
have kids of your own?
- I have one kid.
She took him away.
I never (mutters) I saw a picture,
but that was it.
She said it was my kid,
but I don't know for sure
if he was really my kid or not.
Yeah.
Driver's license, I never
had a driver's license.
I wish I could uh,
have a car before I die.
I haven't been able to get a car,
never had a car in my life.
Never had a house or apartment.
I feel like, almost like
I'm a handicap or something.
(sighs)
(exhales)
- [Interviewer] If there was
one thing about your life
that you could have changed
to change your path and direction,
what do you think that might have been?
That would be?
- (sighs) Murder.
Murder.
- [Interviewer] Do you
still carry that with you
to this day?
- Yep.
Yeah.
I think some day somebody'll shoot me.
That's what this (muttering) paranoid,
going through so many things,
I have to take pills and stuff,
try to get stuff outta my head.
- [Interviewer] How did you kill him?
- Gun.
- [Interviewer] With a gun?
- Yep.
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- I was 13.
13 years old.
So I've been living with that, I'm 58 now.
So it's really have a
toll on my life, you know,
my mind and stuff.
And after dealing with abusive family,
drunks,
lack of love,
care,
barely had clothes,
shoes.
(sighs)
I had to hustle, try to
hustle up our own food
'cause they messed money up.
(crying)
You have uh.
(sighs)
So try to,
try to maybe get some counseling.
I tired before,
maybe, I don't know.
I take medications.
Often time I think about
committing suicide.
I'm suicidal
because of all of that.
I was molested as a child.
(sighs)
- [Interviewer] Who molested you?
- My dad.
(sighs)
(crying)
Since I was, this is how my life is now.
I'm homeless.
I have a little tent that
I'm trying to sleep in.
(sighs)
I have no real friends. (sighs)
- [Interviewer] Do you use
drugs to help you deal with
any of the stuff you went through?
- [Ray] (sighs) Alcohol,
drugs sometime,
pills,
to sedate myself from the voices.
Still hear my dad's voice
hollering at my mother
and her hollering at me
and putting me in a box.
It's a lot of stuff,
a lot of stuff.
It's been so bad
for me.
(sighs) I think one day of,
that's the thing,
maybe I'll find a million
dollars or something.
(sighs) And buy a house and a car
and maybe get married.
(wheezing)
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- Yeah.
She left me.
We was together for three years and
finally she left.
She met somebody else.
I couldn't take care of her.
So,
(crying)
Parts of my life like this
other people (mutters)
they have good lives.
They have good family.
(sighs)
I was thinking about
committing suicide lately,
it's been bothering me.
'Cause of the pain in my life.
(muttering) I love their kids.
It's a mystery to 'em like that.
Some other,
makes me violent.
(sighs)
(wheezing)
(crying)
I apologize for
for tears, it's crying stuff.
(crying)
I don't know what I would do,
(sighs)
(exhales)
but I try really hard
though, to deal with it.
Nobody really cares.
Wish I coulda shared a
great story with you,
but that's been my life.
That's been my life.
- [Interviewer] All right, Ray,
well thank you for coming
in and sharing your story.
- Thank you for letting me share.
(sighs)
(crying)